oh so much purple thanks purple people
let's play very weird name
very weird name always asks very good
questions and we've never played before
I guess we've never played good luck
also I have T forgot God made team
before I started it's been brewing for
over 18 minutes cuz that's my up time
let's play let's play this move again
it's my new opening ok the cards are now
square or rectangular alright let's find
out of 6 I was watching some Carlsen
enter blitz and he was playing this
garbage but it's actually like
interesting garbage thanks for the game
oh thank you Jacob Marshall games maybe
that was my last opponents yeah fun game
and actually played like I'd say the way
you played the opening was definitely
much above your rating it was just a
matter of minimizing blunders and not
giving me free stuff so this is another
position like I was studying last night
Carlsen went through a phase where he
was playing this a lot online even he's
play that in some of these rapid blitz
events against Anand he beat on on with
this this opening card wanna I think
this is called the Norwegian rat
like it looks non-threatening but can
cause a lot of suffering if you're not
careful I got stage fright plus I
usually play rabid yeah getting stage
fright like during a chess game is a
worst you just have to pretend that no
one's watching so I like I had this
position as I was studying
recent private me chess study and I'm
trying to remember when I was preparing
I think it starts with rook g8 an idea
is to try and provoke g3 and weaken the
light squares this is the trap this is
the trap Rep Eric Rosen wrapping and
trapping the rabbit and trapping this is
the trap rub oh man someone has to like
make a beat and then remix that hole
whatever that was and create a song no
I'm not I'm not gonna rap unless my
point falls for a trap other people can
clap it's Batman no it's not that man
did the Mike just break oh no something
if something's wrong with the audio I've
been hanging like them issues with them
Mike because wait this is a free pawn
and this is a free pawn
I wonder i must reflect that rap just
broke everything
um- e6 she had Eric who is Chad keep
hearing this meme but I know it Chad you
sounded like evil all the Sun hmm I try
not to be too evil but evil ackwards
it's live yes people are watching me
live Eric say come to the dark side do
that count is saying it Oh
let's take upon yeah I don't know I
don't know how it happens um it's
happened once before and it's some weird
issue with the make I think but okay
I'll fix it after the scene and some
people appreciate the presence of of
Batman or I am your father
only if I adopt you but that requires
paperwork let's play Bishop and we could
dig queens they all trade greens and
then play 94 this'll be nice now I'm
attacking stuff as soon as you see
threats
Medea I used to just keep applying
pressure
I got a potentially three more attackers
take the very delicate TV pong
I'm not everyone father but I'm ten
antennas away from becoming Evans father
take a while though can you say evil
things please I feel like if I say evil
things that doesn't require these or
thank you gastric Gauri welcome back
shout out to Gauri Gauri will I see you
this weekend maybe maybe not okay let's
yeah I mean well I played this move it
allows night see - mmm maybe I will see
you this is coming like black hat
attacking from all sorts of directions
Nicola thanks for the bits
welcome back Nicola is it Nicola or
Nicola as I heard different
pronunciations I don't know which vowel
to stress there is no Eric on the zoo
zoo or Zuul oh no stream hey Chris is
error thanks for the long time no sub
for three months
yeah if you're just joining something
weird happens but I'm weathering
whatever is happening oh the lather
niccola so Nikola right trying with us
okay now these errors are so nice the
only way to make life better is to
somehow make this bishop come to light
so the bishop might like find its way to
g7 and then just Massacre everything on
the diagonal now this is really nice but
the problem for white nothing is
developed except the bishop been kind of
looking okay like I take the pawn right
away yeah well this is nice
because once I Castle the rook will be
aligned the files open now the King can
me wrong but I don't think it can hide
is that evil enough I have to be evil by
moves
in my spare time I'm a singer for a
death metal band I've never sung death
metal it sounds too deadly can you say
something in German please nein nein
weird the Borg your biological and
technological distinctiveness will be
added to our own resistance is futile
not sure if I understand that
thanks for the bits yeah where's Dani
Dani Dani is probably responsible for
this madness has wizardy wizardy powers
okay let's hassle it's incredible but
the king the King can't it can't run and
it can't really hide
I mean it's hiding behind my mates but
my knight about to move all these
squares like we can't go here hey thanks
for solving point town King appreciate I
appreciate all the love and supports
even if my my voice is a bit off I like
white can I avoid adulthood discovered
check something scary
something scary I know I feel like
scaring this is not part of my my like
overall personality Covino thanks for
subbing I mean
if anything is scary it's the
configuration my pieces do you have any
good advice in the middle game I often
make the wrong decisions when it comes
to placing the pieces and maybe a little
too impatient to attack hmm yeah I mean
there's a lot of law different factors
that go into middle gameplay there's
like middle gamer is such a vast phase
of chess in different situations call
for different strategies with what I'm
not sure exactly what you're referring
to you can you can say thank you tonight
bots not sure if it will recognize those
words I want to imitate i'ma take and
then Bishop h6 and then have fun I mean
this is probably the whoa
Graham ster gari just during the 10k
patch thanks cardi without 100 bits as
ice cheer to put you over the top yeah I
think sometimes in life you just have to
be patient like I want the the desserts
but ft my vegetables first a my pot has
gifted has has received a gifted sub
from Nicola thanks Nicola
maybe someday nightbot will learn how to
express gratitude I take this can take
this and then okay like the king is
gonna try and trap my rook but then I'll
try and jemmye at the king it's a circle
of life when nightbot starts gifting you
you know the the end of the days are
coming it's kind of true umm what to do
I mean I won't still not play this move
it's kind of weird
[Music]
let's are with this move I was trying to
calculate King f1 and then maybe I moved
back maybe I take a look Sooni choices
my voice sounds different
that's what happens why don't stream for
so many days oh my poin resigns my
opponent prolly resign not realizing how
to save save material but after King f1
I think White's still in the game
I mean I'm up a pawn and blacks really
better but it should be lost I guess my
point did have like 10 seconds left
okay maybe this was be bad for what yeah
there's a lot of pressure here anyway I
should probably fix this mic issue but
should I put this on youtube
you go put this on youtube I'll have
some Batman themed thumbnail or Darth
Vader or evil I don't know I have to
figure out why this is happening because
like my mic is brand new it could be the
cable okay people on YouTube thanks for
watching let me know what voice you
prefer and in the meantime is it still
really this bad on newts okay so this is
really just gonna be a test of how bad
siz so obviously really just gonna be a
test how bad okay this is pretty bad one
sec
you
is it better now
unmute is it better now yes okay it's
better now I think I fixed it
let's go sorry people who did not enjoy
that and had to endure that but we're
back to normal
our people upsets some people are upset
I really have no idea it's how it
happens
maybe you hit second puberty it's like
the opposite of helium